I saw this tweet the other day from
Crystal Ball Valenzuela asserting that
the future of human interfaces for
software would be all natural language
and that it is essentially the end of
graphical user interfaces
it's such a simple tweet but it really
got me thinking about a lot of things
because it's clear to me that many
things will change when it comes to our
interactions with software and that this
change will definitely come from AI
based uis and of course natural language
based uis are and would continue to be
AI based but we've also seen a lot of
attempts at these like totally natural
language user interfaces we have things
like Siri Google Alexa and then we also
have like web apps that attempt to do
away with things like the navigation bar
in exchange for purely natural language
UI now at least in my experience
especially for the latter
they're just not good they're cool and
unique and Nifty and all that but they
are not better faster to use and really
not even necessarily more intuitive
it's possible this is just a function of
people coming to grips with how to work
with new technologies like this and how
to like develop software and like UI is
a very Advanced and mature field in
figuring out how to change that to be
natural language it will definitely just
take time but I think in general natural
language is often quite slow
one of the first replies that I think I
agreed with at least initially here was
from Rasmus referencing things like
driving cars with voice controls versus
manual input through the steering wheel
for example or gas pedals and all that
but with further thought he's you know
he's not wrong about the actual physical
driving of cars and yet with the car
example he kind of is wrong
we're looking at this through the lens
of interacting with machinery and
software that was built to be manually
interacted with yes a car was built
initially to be manually controlled by
humans so of course thinking of this
example where you might be steering a
car with verbal commands seems very odd
and likely that natural language won't
be the interface for cars but I think
cars are a really great and obvious
example because eventually you almost
certainly will not be driving your car
AI will be physically and metaphorically
so your interaction with your car your
interface in this scenario would be far
more high level in managerial you're
going to hop in and say take me to
destination X you won't be doing the
steering in this way I think it's very
clear natural language UI is a very
likely candidate for the future UI of
cars and it's not so much that you would
be telling your car verbally to steer
left or right all the time because you
won't be doing those mundane tasks
anymore sure maybe natural language once
in a while would be used for like small
minor Corrections like this but it won't
be the majority of time so it's tough to
really think about things like this
because we're so likely to apply our
current way of thinking and seeing and
doing things to this future were the
things that we see think and do are
likely to be just different and then of
course depending on how far into the
future we want to be thinking here are
we considering the possibilities of
things like neural implants and all
these other like meshings of Machinery
into the human body at this point things
get like super nutty and I think I'm
just going to set that aside for now
so the next thing that I think about is
the fact that graphical user interfaces
they go both ways and I think the
original kind of tweet by Crystal Ball
here kind of like ignores that or
forgets that your input is into a
graphical representation and the output
back to you is a graphical
representation
provided you can manually plus visually
do the input you look for without
navigating through a bunch of menus and
all that this is often much faster and
more intuitive
um and and the same is is bat is true
back to you where it's going to be far
faster than if you received some sort of
audio feedback especially natural
language
a picture is worth a thousand words so
to speak right and I often find my
personal biggest frustration with these
more natural language uis is indeed that
information processing like back to me
it's extremely slow compared to uh
visual especially if the output is wrong
or I wanted something else or something
like that it's like it's super tedious
even just reading a sentence back is
faster than hearing it but you can
display theoretically paragraphs of data
in a single image that I can see and
understand in nearly an instant so in
this way I'm not so sure graphical user
interfaces are going away our eyes are
extremely powerful sensors right natural
language is just one of many
abstractions we of humans have just
simply made up it's not really all that
fast and to be honest it's quite old
technology
but again all this depends on really not
the natural language aspect it depends
on how good is the AI that backs up
these applications that we might be
interacting with because
AI itself is highly likely to abstract
away many of the hindrances that we see
right now similarly to the way that
natural language
might replace the car UI and kind of
nullify that well you wouldn't use a
natural language to drive a car argument
well you won't be driving the car
so along the lines of AI just kind of
changing and abstracting Away things I
think one of the AIS that is making
maybe the largest impact that we've ever
seen from AI is GitHub co-pilot it
silently infiltrating all software
development and changing the way that we
program I think five years ago we when
we had maybe some autocomplete stuff and
maybe even some machine learning
attempts for this you might have been
willing to Proclaim that there was
absolutely no way that you could do
software development even just in the
way that we see it today there was no
way that you could do software
development without a mouse and keyboard
right like No Way Beyond a tech demo
could you be doing software engineering
with natural language right
and then comes along GitHub co-pilot
where today you could write a program by
just speaking into the microphone and
it's pretty doable the hard part would
be fixing or changing code that is
generated to maybe making small tweaks
stuff like that
but this is just a tedious thing that
really just needs to be coded and
handled for this is not that's not like
an unsolved task especially because we
have speech recognition all this stuff
you would just be able to say in line
XYZ change X to Y
done like it's doable it's it's done
it's a solved problem so then we have to
start to wonder will we always use a
mouse and keyboard for software
engineering now I know there will be
people who will Proclaim that they will
always use a mouse and keyboard just
like there will be proclamations I mean
they're right now they're hammering away
on their keyboard in the comment section
about how they'll never use AI like
copilot to program citing whatever
various issues they have with it
unfortunately though you're only here
for a short time and times change
will the next Generations be using mouse
and keyboard what about the ones after
that
I think I'll at least be alive to see
software engineering primarily shift
away from using mouse and keyboard and
kind of see the mouse and keyboard
really become relics of the past like a
typewriter or something I wouldn't
necessarily have thought that like a few
years ago but after working with copilot
a lot there's no question on my mind
that software engineering will change
and move away from human hand coding and
typing to a more managerial type of role
really no different than the transition
that we're seeing with cars and arguably
that we've already seen with programming
right it's not that it's not really that
much different from how has programming
changed from say
assembly to maybe C plus plus to python
like python is already a very high level
programming language there's so much
stuff that's abstracted away you don't
really have to think about and again
just like all these other things that
I've mentioned like copilot and all that
there are still the hardliners who are
like I won't ever use that or whatever
that's not really engineering and all
that kind of stuff but the reality is
the world runs with python and does a
lot of development arguably most or I
have to be very careful about the word
that I use here because there's always
going to be people who get angry but
um I guess uh at least in the field of
AI let's say in many other fields python
runs the world okay and so whether you
like are happy about it or not is
irrelevant it just is the case that
abstraction is is and always will be
king and the more that we abstract
things away the more progress and the
more productivity that we have so this
is just the way things tend to go and
the other thing is GitHub co-pilot I
mean it's really like it's it's one of
the first if not the first there are
there were others like for kind of like
uh machine learning based autocomplete
and sometimes they would do multiple
lines but I how I kind of get the sense
that the multiple lines that they were
doing was more uh logic based than AI
based I think GitHub co-pilot likely is
the first true you know large language
model deep learning auto complete slash
AI pair programmer I think this is the
first and
that is crazy because it's just the
first what's the tenth one going to be
like what's the 100th one right what's
that one going to be like and
um and again I I kind of see GitHub
co-pilot for example having a harder
time than maybe some of the ones of the
future because copilot has to interact
with M yes this like user interface that
is quite literally a text editor where
people type into the text editor and all
that so it has to work around those
constraints
but I think that this is the easing into
a new transition a new way of doing
software engineering so getting back to
the question about natural language uis
replacing graphical ones it's kind of
possible given the advancement of AI I'm
not sure it's the advancement of natural
language processing Technologies though
that will definitely power that
transition but it's really just the
advancement of AI
in general and it's not that you'll use
natural language necessarily to navigate
manual based uis it'll be natural
language to navigate those AI based uis
so the UI itself won't really be the
same as the ones that you necessarily
use today and many of the interactions
that you have today that you're thinking
to yourself well how would I do that
with you know I wouldn't want to do that
with natural language
those will just be abstracted away
as is has often been the case over time
with technology and humans use of that
technology things have just constantly
been abstracted away similar to the
argument I just made about like
programming this is just this is how
productivity and advancement works we
just we build on top of things
so anyway it's you know it's been a fun
thought experiment because like I said
in the beginning it was such a simple
tweet
um and I'm not really sure I fully agree
with it or agree because I I think I
think I guess like the the aim is wrong
or something where it's not really it's
not about natural language UI and it's
not about the going away of a graphical
UI it is just simply the future is a far
more intuitive UI most likely or even
maybe the like the this notion of like a
static UI where the maybe the navigation
menu is always the same or something
like that
um I think that's going away but will
all UI be natural language based I don't
know and I definitely think the
interface back to you is still largely
going to be graphical but it's
definitely been a fun thought experiment
either way I certainly don't personally
have all the answers and I am curious
what you think even if you think I don't
know python sucks or whatever
um I also think it's just fun to think
about how much has changed in the last
few years last year or even just like
the last month like when it comes to Ai
and what I'm thinking is going to be
possible in the coming future every
single week it seems like there is a new
release a new update and we don't have
enough time to even consider the impacts
and utility of those updates before
guess what there's another release
another world-changing massively power
Tech powerful technology yet to be
leveraged in any way and it just kind of
comes out and then people sort of talk
about it and move on and it's just it's
a it really is a crazy time uh to be in
this field and to be alive like watching
these things happen like large language
models were massively powerful and cool
when they came out and kind of were
largely arguably other than maybe their
size unchanged up to the point of GitHub
co-pilot and but there was like all this
kind of dissent about whether or not
these models really had had any use at
all but working with them and and like
using them it was so clear this is a
massively powerful technology do I know
how to use it and apply it today to a
thing right now given the current
perspective and lens that I view the
world from no I don't immediately but
but I can clearly see this is
unbelievably powerful technology you
know and it's hard to see how are we
actually going to utilize this and then
years later after the large language
model we have GitHub co-pilot and it's
just so obviously and unquestionably a
massive productivity amplification
and a great application of a large
language model
and again I know that some of you or
maybe even many of you as you clutch
your mechanical keyboards will complain
that you'll never leave and and you know
you would never leave behind the tried
and true and that you'd never associate
yourself with blasphemy like a co-pilot
but I think the field in general will
leave that notion behind it's almost a
guarantee because again
we favor productivity and and like
advancement and I I think as you
abstract away it's just so much easier
to be productive in advance
um I can't even imagine like all the
projects that I've ever done if I had to
do them even just you know a rung down
into like C plus plus I would never be
where I am today and so it's like that
abstraction and and to be clear I
understand like python is built on top
of C plus plus and C plus plus Powers
python but that's exact but that just
further bolsters the point that that's
why abstraction is so powerful right so
so I'm not really sure that's a valid
argument against you know abstraction or
the power it's not like we're leaving
old technology behind we build on top so
anyway as for natural language being the
primary interface
I'm kind of torn here I think graphical
output is still obviously Superior to
audio output and even input often is
also Superior faster more intuitive just
easier to use I I feel like
but if the AI is good enough to where
the only input that you put back into
the system is like high level stuff or
minor Corrections then it is indeed
possible that it is the future right
um anyway let me know your thoughts
below there are certainly many things I
haven't considered here and I'm just
interested to hear what others think
it's just such a like I said it's a
simple topic but also it's it's curious
to think about especially in the context
of
even just some of the major changes in
the last like year for example so
um anyway that's all for now let me know
what you think down below and I will see
you all next time